[Music]
happy birthday dear mom happy birthday
to you good morning John it's Friday
March 16th today is an important day for
Brotherhood 2.0 for more than one reason
of significant importance to Brotherhood
2.0 is a Frank who likely inspired an
awful lot of what we're doing here maybe
even a little bit more than we realized
sometimes say Frank has made a hilarious
video every weekday for the past year by
doing this he has garnered international
attention in publication in the New York
Times and a viewership of hundreds of
thousands we would like to be as popular
as a Frank but we will never be because
we aren't anywhere near as cool as a
Frank but starting today that doesn't
matter anymore
say Frank viewers won't be able to watch
say Frank anymore
thus I think say Frank viewers maybe
should come check out the Brotherhood
welcomes a frank viewers any of you out
there isn't it gonna be a horrible life
without having say Frank to
procrastinate with you can Preston ate
with us I mean we blink say Frank
doesn't blink we write songs though but
they're not as good as say Frank songs
and we have projects that our viewers
can participate in with us but none of
them are anywhere near as cool as making
the entire world a sandwich second
reason that this is a very important day
for Brotherhood to point out is because
there is only one person who is vital to
the creation of the Brotherhood and that
is our mom actually today isn't mom's
birthday tomorrow was mom's birthday but
tomorrow there's a Saturday but there
won't be any brother 22.0 in tomorrow so
I'm taking the opportunity to celebrate
mom's birthday Adair Lee on Brotherhood
2.0 now there really is no one who's
more important to Brotherhood 2.0 than
our mom I mean we both came out of her
and I really and truly want to thank her
for that
I know it must not have been very fun I
have a pretty big head and I guess it
didn't really get all that much easier
for you I mean that first day was bad
and then there were probably some bad
days pretty soon after that I know there
were some bad days a few years after
that and then high school was like all
bad days and then I went to college and
I just never called you oh happy
birthday mom having kids kind of sucks
but I hope you know that they appreciate
you your support has been vital this
might seem a little bit stupid or
callous or maybe even inhuman but I
think you should be able to own stock in
people so for example when a child is
born the parents have a minority stake
in the interests of the child whereas
the child would own a full 51% of itself
the parents would only own 49 the child
could never sell its majority stake but
the parents could sell their minority
stake to different people like when the
kid goes off to college the parents
could sell like 10% of the kid to the
college and that way the college can get
something back from the kid for what it
gives to the kid and then later the kid
might want to buy some of his stock back
from you so he'll have more than a 51%
stake in his self-knowing my mom she'd
probably just give me that 49% and I
don't a hundred percent of myself but it
seems somehow wrong that people can put
so much energy into a person and then
that person gets to take all that energy
and do whatever they want with it mom
shouldn't you be getting something back
you invested a lot of time and effort
and worry and discomfort in me and I
feel bad that I just have all that stuff
that you gave me and I can do whatever I
want with it I guess what I'm trying to
say is moms are great and they do it all
for nothing
I'll see you on Monday
and if the world were a sandwich we
could all be one sandwich